Hello and welcome to...
my new show,
"Kill Yourself for Views"
Episode 1
There is no show, there is no challenge...
I'm just going to eat a bunch of hot sauces.
We discovered that..
the content is irrelevant on YouTube these days
It's just all about the title, so..
I thought we'd live up to the title
and...
end my life.
I've been doing YouTube for 6 years, you'd think I'm above this at this point.
I don't want to do this, I genuinely don't wan-
zoom in on my face
I don't want to fuckin' do this.
This is dumb.
Oh....
My!
Is this the challenge?
"Lets give you a nice easy hot sauce first"
Oh I wonder what this one could be
It's time to eat some chicken!
It's good ^-^
I like it.
Next, "LootCrate Hot-Sauce"
I hope this one is the one that does the trick!
Now you know this is spicy because it doesn't all come out, you know?
It only comes out in lil' drips..
Is this made out of..
pussy...
It's not.
I got nothing
This video has been brought by "LootCrate"
Next, "LootCrate Hot-Sauce"!
I will say that I am starting to develop a little bit of a spice in my mouth
Well this one doesn't smel--
OH JESUS!
Hello! Alright, lets get it all up in there...
"Oh My God!"
That was so unnecessary
Who bought these?
I mean it's spicy...
This one took a lil' while to...
this one came a little later
"I wouldn't recommend it anymore.
Cause that one was actually..."
"the poison one!"
"We poisoned one!"
"So this stuff is... fucking horrendous"
NO!
"We poisoned one! Gotcha!"
"Remember this? Remember this stuff?"
You guys killed me!
"This might put him in hospital and I just..
I just put that on camera.. so there we go."
Oh my god!
"Don't eat anymore, you're crazy..."
"I put a whole pipette of this..
crazy stuff in it..."
You actually did it?
"Yeah!"
Micheal for real?
"Yeah"
"You just ate more of it I don't know why!"
You poisoned me!
You fucking bitch Romanian!
I can't talk... it burns.
You know, part of my is angry...
but the other part is real proud...
that you tried to kill me.
Next one!
The ultimate hot sauce challenge!
Where's that one, gimme that one
here we go...
Jesus Chr-- You guys fed me this shit!?
Dude this will kill me...
This is not funny
I will die!
For the views!
oh my god.
I'm shaking look at me
"alright, quickly!
Before that one wears off, the last hot sauce!"
"the very last one!"
"Warning: This sauce is very hot, use at your own ris"
Oh my god
Oh no
Oh no, what have I done?
oh nooo!
I wanna die...
I wanna die.
Is it that fast?
I think I'm going to shit myself
Why didn't you warn me about the last one!
"Well you just drank it!"
What the fuck is wrong with you!
"No one had a chance, before we knew, you were drinking it from the bottle!"
"That last one is legit- that's the only one I requested"
It's time to review the "LootCrate"
Alright, this is last months "LootCrate: Magic". Lets unbox it!
Oh that feels good!
That feels good.
First of all we have... a t-shirt, from fantastic beasts!
"Fantastic Beasts", have you guys watched the movie?
Did you like it?
I'm not a big Harry Potter, I'm er-an adult!
I'm over it, okay?
I'm in pain
We got, Doctor Strange figure! I'm gonna keep this in the box.. but it's really cool!
and it looks cute, it's cool
We have a Game of Thrones diary I think it is..
"The night is dark.. and full of terrors"
Just like my ass... it's full of terrors right now... except it's a diary...
You want to start right now?
"Dear Diary..."
"my ass is on fire.." xD
We gotta pin
another one huh? *yap*
alright
This one unlocks something epic if you goto "LootCare.com/pins"
it feels like an alien baby is inside of me
There we go... we gotta pin
We got a magazine...
"Big Trouble in lil China: escape from New York"
this is cool
and then we have the explanation of the artifact...
So yeah
It's a pretty cool lootcrate as always, it's fun to get a lootcrate every month and a...
just get a bunch of cool stuff... for a good value... a good price
If you like to collect figurines, LootCrate is a must
Next months theme is "Revolution" and you order before the 19th to get that one...
Goto "LootCrate.com/Pewds"
Enter the code "PEWDS", you get 10% off, you guys know the drill. I really appreciate that you guys check this out..
I think I need, 20 - 30 minuets...
Thank you guys for watching and supporting me! *np <3*
do you have any toilet-paper? *sure :P*